- Did you know that sometimes
when we're not home,
Bridget likes to watch TV naked?
- How do you know this?
- Oh, hey, it's that girl Skyler.
She's so hot.
- Yeah, I have seen her around campus.
- [Together] Think I'm
gonna go talk to her.
What?
- Sorry to burst your bubble there, June,
but I've heard that she
just recently broke up
with her boyfriend.
- Well my bubble is
perfectly intact, thank you,
because I know for a fact
that she has hooked up with several girls
in my acting class, girls.
- Oh.
Our game's afoot.
- Indeed it is, sir.
- You seem very confident.
What makes you think you have
a clear advantage over me?
- I'm a lady.
She's a lady.
We already have way more in common.
So I'm gonna go over there
and I'm gonna compliment her
on her dress.
I'm gonna ask her where she got it from
and then we're gonna
bond over how ravishing
the fall collection from Zara is.
- That is adorable 'cause
I'm just gonna go over there
and tell her how beautiful she is
because it's not about what she's wearing.
- You're right, you're right,
which is why I'm actually
gonna get more specific
and I'm gonna tell her that her eyes
are more beautiful than
the oceans (mumbles).
- The 'ole Bailey's line.
Classic but too forward
'cause I'm just gonna ease
into the conversation.
Buy her a drink, keep it classy.
Tequila.
- Tequila?
- [Man] Um-hmm.
- If you take a look at the lady
she is not a tequila lady.
She is an elegant lady and an elegant lady
deserves an elegant drink,
which is why I'm gonna get her something
more like a 1997 Pinot
Grigio from Napa Valley.
- Like you can afford
anything from the pre 2000s.
I'm gonna go over there,
dazzle her with my wit, charm,
and thorough knowledge
of vintage German yachts.
- Or you could try listening, you know,
ask her about her hopes and dreams.
Be engaged in the conversation.
Make the conversation more about her.
Just some free advice from me to you.
- I'm sorry, I was not listening
because after I get her dying laughing
with my exquisite sense of humor,
while I gently embrace
the small of her back,
she'll be unable to resist
falling truly, madly,
deeply in love with me.
- Okay, easy Savage Garden.
I know a little something
about personal boundaries,
which is why I'm not gonna
touch the small of her back,
but rather graze her arm
lightly and playfully.
- I'm gonna ask her to dance.
- I'm gonna ask her to play pool
and bet her that if I win,
I get to take her on a date.
- I'm gonna buy her more tequila.
- I'm gonna buy her more wine.
- I'm gonna be a perfect gentleman
and make sure she gets home safely.
- I'm going to suddenly
hint that we do this again.
- I'm gonna directly hint
that we do this again.
- I'll bite my lip.
- I'll bite my lip harder.
- Well let's do this then.
- Let's do it.
- Okay, fine.
- Hey.
(grunting)
(mumbles)
(upbeat music)